نعم نحن هنا في درب السيل كما تشاهدون
هناك موكب موكب المنتخب الارجنتيني الذي
فاز بكاس العالم هنا في قطر بقياده ميسي
طبعا
نشاهد في الصوره الموكب الذي يقل
اللاعبون
وهم على متن هذه الحافله ااه في الصوره
واذا شاهدنا الان مباشره بعد الخيول وبشكل
الحصيد العربيه
المنتخب الارجنتيني وهم على متن هذه
الحافله يقومون باجراء التحيه والقاء
التحيه على الجيش على المشجعين الذين
نشاهد هنا هذا هو ال- ال- هذا هو المنتخب
الارجنتيني على متن هذه الحافله يقومون
همم بالقاء التحيه على جميع همم
المشجعين والذين يهتفون ميسي واسماء اخرى
من لاعبي المنتخب ويقولون راموس ارخنتينا
لحظات تاريخيه لحظات تاريخيه ونشاهد ايضا
خلف حافله اللاعبين نشاهد الحافله الرسميه
التي تنقل اللاعبين بعد ذلك عندما ينتهوا
من عبر درب الوسيله او من عبور ضرب الوزير
همم من عبور ضرب الوسيل من عبور درب
الوسيل متجهين على متن حافلاتهم الى مكان
اقامتهم التي طبعا هناك ستقام احتفالات
خاصه لهم والجماهير بانتظارهم امام هذا
الفندق او مكان الاقامه ومن ثم ستنتهي
الاحتفالات في ساعات الصباح الباكر ليث
بزاري العربيه الدوحه قطر